battle begins in three if you combine
the artificial intelligence of a Spiro
the Bluetooth enabled bot with the
nostalgia of a Hot Wheels track you
might get something like the Anki
overdrive the smart real-life racing
game sets you up with a giant track and
remote-control cars except these cars
are being controlled by an app on your
phone the cars intelligently scan the
track and then you're off to the races
twisting and turning and viewing your
opponent's battle with virtual weapons
that can disabled vehicles you can even
play against all these artificial
intelligence which learns your style of
driving adapts and keep it pushing the
play at least that's the idea
while Anki overdrive is undeniably a lot
of fun it has its hiccups sometimes cars
hurtle themselves off the track or
sometimes they can't make the jump or
drive around the track backwards these
switches don't mean Anki overdrive won't
keep you entertained racing a car around
a track has never been a terribly
complex game but it's definitely a fun
one now is it a few hundred dollars
worth of fun no and no it's not but the
starter kit which costs $150 is
definitely a more compelling price
you'll get your speeding kicks without
the frustration of shelling out for what
can be a glitchy experience